Speaker 1: Let's go to LJ from
Vegas, LJ. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, how's it going?
Speaker 1: It's going well.
Speaker 5: And I kind of had a question
for you, but I kind of had to set the
stage. But that's okay.
Speaker 1: All right.
Speaker 5: So kind of the comment I wanted to have
is this kind of idea that the left is responsible
for all cancel culture that is out there right now
at the moment. I have a friend of mine. He's not
a MAGA, you know, maggot, in other words. But he
does lean more towards the right when it comes to
his ideals of what the left actually represents.
And we have a lot of different discussions about
how certain actors that he likes, certain people
that he likes to follow and enjoys listening to,
always seem to get yelled at by the left, and
they always seem to be trying to be canceled. So I
my personal introspect and the things that
I give to him in response to that is, hey.
It's more accountability than it is canceling. Do
you feel that these actions that this person let's
take, you know, someone who might sexually abuse
somebody or someone who might do something that's
incorrect in the limelight and gets caught for
it. Yeah. Do these do you feel that they're
personally okay to come back and be
accepted? And he says, absolutely,
as long as they apologize for it. And I kind of
want to get your idea of like, what do you think
is a good way to apologize for someone
that has been, let's say, canceled,
quote, unquote.
Speaker 1: Well, okay. So first of all.
If you kill someone and then say, I'm sorry I did
it, you don't get out of the consequences, right?
So let's like first sometimes it's good to have
like an extreme example to frame the conversation.
So first of all, we all have to agree that
certain bad acts have to be punished regardless
of remorse, I think. Right. And different people
maybe would disagree on that once we get to that.
Take, for example, someone like, do
you know who the chef Mario Batali is?
Speaker 5: No, I.
Speaker 1: Don't. He's. He was like a TV chef,
and he had a big social media presence. And then
he was accused. I hope I'm being correct here. He
was accused of sexual harassment for when he was
on a program, I think, called The Chew. And then
he basically disappeared from the social media
space. And it's been years and there was recently
some trial and. Let me see if I can even find the
outcome so we can be accurate. Mario Batali trial
like he was basically canceled. Okay. He was found
a few months ago not guilty of indecent assault
and battery on Tuesday. So let's imagine how he
was canceled. How can he credibly kind of like
come back? Well, I think there's a few components
here. Number one, it's been a long enough period
where it's plausible that he could say, even
though I was exonerated legally for what happened.
I feel terrible that I made anybody uncomfortable.
I regret my actions. Here's what I've done. I now
understand, you know? And so you put together
all these things is like exoneration in a trial.
And it's been a while. And he seems to
understand what he did wrong. All right. Well,
it seems realistic and believable. And we
can say, all right, let him start doing his
cooking show again or whatever the case may
be, and we'll watch. It contrasts that with
someone who's accused of something horrible. The
next day goes, I'm sorry if people were offended.
And now we're supposed to say, Oh, yeah, that's
totally cool. Yeah, they're fine now in my book.
No, it's not credible. It's not plausible.
So I don't know that there's necessarily any
sort of like checklist or playbook, but as people
we can look at situations and kind of figure out
how we feel about particular
situations and just like be
reasonable people evaluating the world around us.
Speaker 5: I can give you a specific one because
I just pull it out right now. You
were discussing Andrew Tate. Yeah,
and so I don't know if you know who he is, right?
Speaker 1: As I know, Andrew Tate is like some
kind of, uh, I don't know, he's kind of
like a, like a I. I don't even know how
to describe it. He's a guy who, I guess had
many relationships with women. I don't know.
Speaker 5: I didn't want to learn about him.
Right. Yeah. I was forcibly dragged into this
conversation because he had been listening
to Andrew Tate recently and he's like, Oh,
no, man. All he cares about is like the
the strength of men and men's place in the
world. And he was discussing all these
things and I'm just like holding my.
Speaker 2: Head, like, please stop. Like, just.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I know. So I can tell you I
don't know enough about that situation to
really be able to comment intelligently.
Speaker 5: Absolutely. And I don't want to give
like a shortened version of it. Right. But it was
more of the fact that it's like, oh, Andrew
Tate deleted all the videos where he's like
being a comedian. He's just trying to
make jokes. And I tried to explain to him
that wouldn't be enough, right? That that
is not a admission of guilt. That's not an
admission of right. You had the wrong opinion.
I agree. It's just deleting old stuff so you
can stay on YouTube or whatever it is.
Speaker 1: Yep, totally. Yeah. That's
not credible. It's not it doesn't seem
substantive to me. I agree. Yeah. So that's it.
So I think the answer is we all kind of
intuitively know when these apologies
are credible and then we evaluate that.
Speaker 5: Yeah, definitely. I agree.
Speaker 1: All right, LJ, thank you for the call.
I appreciate everybody who called in. We will take
calls again, but no more for today. We will take
a quick break and I'll see everybody very soon.